Yeah, I'm one of the, I have this theory
and we see it in sports and I saw it when
I talked to him and he's been a friend
of mine for a long time and I was talking
to him about his psychology is he goes
into a football game and he says he plays
a movie in his mind of the entire game
before he plays it.
Because you know,
in a football game you're going to have
11 or 12 possessions during the game and
you just throw that football game.
You can get that ball 11 or
12 times and he would say,
and I'm going to carry that ball
three or four times per possession,
and he knows which plays he's going to
run. He would run him through his head,
he would see it, he would know who was
going to be there to tackle him. He would,
you know,
he'd run everything through his head and
he's one of those guys that wants the
ball when the clock's running out.
But I have this theory that situations
do not make heroes situations expose
heroes.
And I saw that in Katrina,
the hurricane that so devastated
that that one neighborhood,
what ward was it does it the ninth ward,
and I forget which ward it
was that got so wiped out, uh,
when Katrina hit New Orleans and there
was a guy down there that had been really
quiet. Nobody had ever heard anything
out of him. He was an older guy,
lived in a house,
stayed to himself.
And that night when the
water was at rooftop level,
I mean he swam rooftop
to rooftop and save six,
seven, eight people got 'em out of
there and he didn't make it out,
but he got seven or eight people out of
there and you go back and you check his
history and he was a military hero.
He just sat quietly in his home.
And when the situation came about,
it revealed who he was.
And I think that's what happens.
I think if you've got a hero,
they just sit there,
sit there and sit there until the
situation reveals who they are.
I don't think it makes him a hero.
I think it reveals that they're heroes.
And I think that's what happens to people.
They,
they are who they are until they get in,
in the opportunity to comes along and
they're going to show you who that is and
they may show you are a coward or they
may show you that they've got the focus
to hang or they may show
you that they're a hero,
but life circumstances are going to come
along and we're going to show you who
somebody is. Yeah, I completely agree.
And I think what's also interesting is
when someone does get revealed to be a
coward, they can become
a hero. It's very hard.
It's very hard to get past the
memory of you being a coward.
Well, I'll tell you why I think that's
true. If you want to know please.
I mean maybe I'm going away,
going off on a tangent.
Come on now I think.
I think learn about ourselves and yo
everybody talks about self esteem and self
worth,
but nobody ever talks about what
it really is or how we get it.
And I think I think about it in terms
of self attribution because you know how
you form opinions of other people.
Like if you look at this guy and you,
you maybe you work with this guy and so
you watch him across a couple of years
and maybe this guy shows up to work
every day and he's there 15 minutes early
and he unlocks the place, gets
everything ready, puts a coffee on,
has his desk ready,
he's all buttoned up and Ma'am when the
bell rings he's ready to go. And you,
you just learned that this
guy's buttoned up, ready to go.
Dependable never misses.
He's always there.
So you attribute certain traits and
characteristics to him based on your
observations of him and your experience
of him based on that you assign certain
traits and characteristics to him.
But I say that's exactly the same way
we form our own self image and our own
level of self worth.
We watch ourselves go through life
and we watch how we handle certain
circumstances and situations.
And that's why I say overindulgence is
one of the most insidious forms of child
abuse Mellon to parenting.
Uh, it's not the worst.
It's just insidious because
if you overindulge your
children and do everything
for them, you never let them observe
themselves, master their environment.
You never let them step back
and say, wow, I did that,
I built this, I overcame that,
I handled this, I did that.
And so we,
that's the same way we make our own
self image and level of self worth.
We watch ourselves
overcome the third grade.
We watch ourselves stand up to a bully,
we watch ourselves handle a test with
the information that intimidated us or we
watch ourselves make it onto the little
league baseball team and actually get a
hit when we needed to.
Where we watch ourselves get on to the
debate team and actually argue something
successfully, whether it's
academic or athletic or musical.
We watch ourselves do it. And so we'd
go back and say, Hey, I did that.
I attribute to myself the ability,
I can hang, I can do this,
I can rise to the occasion.
Or we watch ourselves fold like a
pup tent in a windstorm and say,
I can't hang out.
I don't have it.
And we make those
attributions to ourselves.
And so we strength from the challenge
for the rest of our lives until like you
said,
it's hard to overcome that and something
pushes you up until you finally observe
yourself overcome something.
And I think that's how we form our level
of self esteem and our identity about
who we are. And I don't think most people
think about that. Look back and say,
okay, how did I, how did I get to be
Joe Rogan has a sit in that chair.
You have a self image, you have a
level of confidence, ego, strength, uh,
a level of self worth that's attributable
to things you've watched yourself do
or not do, achieve, not achieve,
overcome or whatever throughout your life.
And,
and I think to know yourself,
you have to know what those things are.
I think you're 100% right.
And I think for children participating
in things that are going to test you so
critical, giving them this
opportunity to realize that the, the,
there's a line between success and failure
and that you could push through that
line and you could,
you could become successful at
something and learn watching kids at.
That's why I think sports are
so important for children.
I think that's one of the more insidious
things about having these participation
trophies for kids where that nobody
wins the game. Yay. Everybody plays,
but nobody wins. We don't keep score.
Well, why the fuck are you plan? Yeah.
I mean that just goes down as an
environmental non event. Yeah.
I mean that that contributes nothing to
your definition is just something to do.
It's also psychologically it's coddling.
It's very,
it's very damaging for your potential
education that you would get from that
situation.
The bad feeling that you get when someone
scores on you is motivation for you to
be better at defense.
Yeah.
You know,
I think we cheat kids when we do that
and of course you gotta play everybody.
I get that not everybody is meant
to be an athlete, so, okay, look,
go do something else.
Be Good at what you're good at.
Yeah. And if you really want to do
it well, you've got a long road.
It's a greased hill start running.
Yeah.
It's just everything's not for everybody.
So find what you're good at and
watch yourself achieve in that lane.
You know, that's like I could, I
can't carry a tune in a bucket.
I, I can't even, I can play
no instrument. I can't sing.
I can play a radio if it's got
a big on off knob. That's it.
And so I don't try, I mean
that's, I'm just not good at that.
So I go into lanes that I can do
stuff and observe myself in that.
But I think you cheat kids if you
don't let them observe themselves face
adversity and overcome it.
Absolutely. And it's also an interesting
lesson to learn that life isn't fair.
I mean,
if you're a kid and you're playing
basketball with a 15 year old Lebron James
and you're my height, you go, Huh, yeah.
This ain't gonna work out at all. Yeah,
you're looking at a towel boy here.
This is not fucking happening.
And you have to be able to
understand that and appreciate that.
And then conversely, if you're
very physically frail, you know,
maybe wrestling's not for you either.
You know, maybe, maybe you, uh,
we need to do something about your
body before you engage in any sort of a
combat sport. You know,
they did an experiment,
I think it was the 60s they did
something called teaching machines.
Have you ever seen that? It was
a short period of time, but they,
they took students in the class where
they put the steps of learning the
information so close together that
there was never a failure experience.
It would say like the war
of 1812 happened in 1812.
Then the next thing would say the
war of 1812 happened in blank.
You fill in 18, 12. I mean, come
on. Potted plant could get that.
So they've put it together and they would
teach the information and they would
teach it to criteria where
you mastered the information.
You had it 100% and I
said, wow, this is great.
Everybody learned it. So everybody made
a hundred, everybody got the information,
they truly did learn it.
There was no question about it.
They learned the information
and so they did great.
And then they took him out of that
program and put them back in the regular
classroom.
And the first time they came to questions,
they didn't know the answer to the first
time they didn't get a hundred they
came apart like a cheap suit.
They panicked,
they didn't know how to handle adversity,
they didn't know how to handle it when
they didn't have the right answers,
they didn't learn how to not be perfect.
And so they scrapped the whole program
because he said you can't do this because
that's not the way life is.
Right. And if I mean it's,
you're not teaching how
the real world works,
you might as well teach them to go on
red and stop on green and then give them
the keys and put them out in life.
Cause that's not the way it works.
And those kids were absolutely screwed
up when they got into a truly competitive
environment.
It can't be success only.
Yeah. It doesn't make any sense. It's
not healthy. It's not good for you.
You don't learn from it.
I mean,
the whole idea about school is you're
supposed to be setting kids up for the
future. He supposed to be teaching
them not just information,
but teaching them how to learn and
prove. Yeah, and that
worries me. You know,
I read that story not long
ago when you students,
I think it was at Ucla in law school,
complained and got a professor either
disciplined or fired because he required
them to take a counter argument over
something controversial like Ferguson.
He said, I want you to, you know,
I know you that you're
all on this point of view.
Now I want you to prepare an argument for
the other side. And they all said, ah,
that's, that's upsetting
to us. We just can't do it.
And they went to the
administration and complained.
Wow, that's crazy. Because you
may have to do, as a lawyer,
you may have to represent someone who's
done something you don't agree with.
If that's what you want to do for a right.
I mean,
are you kidding me?
They were like needed therapy.
Uh, my, what the hell has happened here?
Oh my God. That's so crazy. That's nuts.